[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is Sky News Today Live from leviv
in Western Ukraine it's three o'clock
here one o'clock in the UK our top
stories
signs of Hope in mariopol officials say
there are survivors of an attack on a
theater where more than 1 000 people
were Sheltering for safety
pictures emerge of the families who are
in hiding while the number killed in the
assault remains unclear
everything
a fourth Russian general killed as
Western intelligence suggests President
Putin's Invasion has largely stalled on
all fronts
the Kremlin claims it's working hard on
peace talks but President Putin says
Western sanctions will only make Russia
stronger
large Russian business structures which
used to be scared of some sanctioned
measures now they have nothing to fear
and young lives devastated by War we
report from Kiev as President
zielinski's Chief of Staff tell Sky news
Ukraine refuses to give up its territory
[Music]
well hello and good afternoon we are
live in LA Viv in Western Ukraine three
weeks into President Putin's invasion of
this country today as the besieged city
of mariopol found itself once again the
focus of Russia's bombardment this
afternoon there are some signs of Hope
an official at the city's mayor's office
says there are survivors after Russia
attacked A theater where more than 1 000
people including children were
Sheltering for safety well at the moment
the number of people killed is unknown
but reports suggest the underground bomb
shelter did withstand the assault we'll
get more on that in just a moment first
then let's take you through all of the
rest of the day's developments
well the UK Ministry of Defense says the
Russian invasion has largely stalled on
all fronts and that Russian forces have
made minimal progress on land sea and
air in recent days Russia's foreign
Ministry says talks are continuing with
Ukraine via video link with the sides
discussing military political and
humanitarian issues a fourth Russian
general has been killed according to
Ukrainian officials 47 year old Major
General Oleg material reportedly died
during the storming of mariopol and
Ukraine's president zielinski addressed
Germany's Parliament this morning
telling members that some sanctions came
too late to stop the war Skies Charlotte
Lomas reports
a man ashes a camera to see inside
maripole theater the old coat check-in
now a place to line up for food this
footage verified by Sky News was filmed
before the attack at every turn you see
women and children seeking safety in
this besieged city
outside satellite images show the
theater days before the bombing the
Russian word for children spelled out on
the ground
this is what's left of marapal theater
now
yet another sign of Russian aggression
against civilians in this war
the number of casualties is not known
but it's believed hundreds of people
were Sheltering inside
Russia has denied carrying out the
attack but it is a city Russian troops
have encircled
tens of thousands of people are trapped
inside mariopol and are quickly running
out of water food and medicines
hospitals in the city are overwhelmed
with no morgue this doctor was left to
leave dead bodies in the basement
I don't know where we will put them How
We will bury them I have no idea he says
local officials have said more than two
and a half thousand people have been
killed but in reality because of the
shelling the number of dead cannot be
counted
but still this is a city putting up
strong resistance
here a Russian tank on an otherwise
Empty Street comes under attack
in Ukraine's Capital Kiev another day
bringing some more Devastation a block
of flats hit when a missile was shot
down
at least one person has been killed and
three others injured
the 35-hour long curfew on this city has
now been lifted and while the Russian
Advance seems to have halted it's by no
means over for those left in the city is
an uneasy wait for what happens next
president zielinski though says Ukraine
is ready to fight in his latest video
address to the German Parliament he
criticizes Western leaders for putting
the economy first
we asked you about preventive sanctions
with
urged Europe to many countries who urged
you
such sanctions that the enemy felt that
you're a force but you delayed we
understood that you wanted to support
your economy economy economy
talks continue on how to end this war
with Russia saying it's in discussion
with Ukraine via video link but this
will do nothing to stop The Exodus of
people with thousands leaving Ukraine
every day any peace deal for this
country will involve compromise one
difficult to envisage Charlotte Lomas
Sky News
well let's look at the situation across
the country then and as we've been
saying the Russian ground Invasion has
stalled according to analysts you can
see the areas of Russian control on this
map but attacks on cities around the
countries continue and know and more so
than in mariopol the theater attacked
yesterday is at the center of the
besieged city and the Russian troops
surrounding the city have repeatedly
targeted residential areas to the West
Odessa is still in Ukrainian hands
Russian naval ships have been firing at
Targets along the coast and an MP from
the region told Sky News that the city
is preparing to defend itself in the
north and genev it's also been pounded
by Russian Firepower for weeks now the
original Governor says that 53 people
were killed by Russian troops yesterday
13 of them while queuing for bread and
in the capital this morning one person
was killed and others injured after an
intercepted Missile hit it a residential
area
well in the last hour we heard from
President Putin who responded to the
escalation of Western sanctions on
Russia
he's been chairing a meeting on the
economic development of Crimea ahead of
the anniversary of its annexation and
admitted the international clampdown
imposed by other countries has had an
impact on his plans for the region but
claimed the sanctions will open other
doors
restrictions imposed on Russia they of
course creates many problems
but not just problems they also open new
opportunities and and we have for
example now that large Russian business
structures which used to be scared of
some sanctioned measures now they have
nothing to fear
well NATO's Secretary General says the
military Alliance is determined to stop
the war in Ukraine from escalating
further speaking in berlinia and
stotenberg welcomed German Chancellor
Olaf Schultz's efforts to find a
diplomatic solution to the conflict but
he added that Vladimir Putin's War had
shattered peace and shocked the world
NATO has a responsibility to prevent
this conflict from escalating further
that would be even more dangerous and
would cause more suffering death and
destruction German is also stepping up
to help protect and defend all the NATO
allies
with more troops in Lithuania
fight the Jets in Romania and ships on
patrol
this is part of NATO's Swift decisive
and United response to this
fundamentally changed security
environment
well peace talks between Russia and
Ukraine are continuing via video link
there are some signs of progress so what
does each side want well Russia has
reportedly demanded that Ukraine
renounce its ambition to join NATO a
neutral status for Ukraine would be
declared along the lines of Austria or
Sweden under international law
neutrality prohibits States from
interfering in conflicts or territorial
disputes
and Russia also wants Kiev to promise
not to allow foreign military bases or
weapons in Ukraine
meanwhile Ukraine's first demand is a
ceasefire and the withdrawal of Russian
troops an official in President
zielinski's office has said Kiev is
insisting on a legally binding document
with security guarantees for Ukraine
these could come from specific
agreements with Western allies but it's
unlikely Moscow would accept that unless
Russia was also named guarantor and it's
unclear how that could work
well the same Ukrainian official also
said the main subject under discussion
was whether rushing troops would remain
in separatist regions in eastern Ukraine
after the war and where the borders of
those regions would be
whilst guys Nick Martin is in Odessa the
Ukrainian Port City on the Black Sea and
obviously a real aim of President Putin
is to Take Over Control of the Black Sea
we see the fighting at at one end in
mariopol and the preparations where you
are Nick in Odessa
yeah that's right we're we're down right
on the on the shore here this afternoon
in Odessa and this morning we saw some
video on social media some Stills which
suggested that there was a a naval
military presence out here in the Black
Sea there were quite grainy pictures on
the long end of a lens so by no means uh
you know near here but there was five or
six uh Naval Russian ships what we think
were that uh building up here in the
Black Sea and that would kind of tally
with with what we've been uh hearing of
course this is one of the major seaports
in Ukraine the others are Mario Paul and
michelia these are two cities that have
already suffered sustained fighting
sustained damage and strategically and
militarily very important for Vladimir
Putin here they are trying to prepare
for that the theory being that they they
would expect that the forces would come
from the north and from the East and try
to encircle this city before any kind of
offensive from the sea we will wait and
figure out whether that actually happens
we were in the town earlier we were
watching some children just drawing with
chalk on the Pavements of the one of the
main squares here when the air raid
sirens rang out I have to say that the
odessens they're not they're not
particularly perturbed about the air
raid sirens a lot of people just carried
on what they were doing but one family
seemed to know better and we went down
into the to the subway with them and I
got chatting with them and they were
from nikolaev their street had been
shelled and nine people had died they'd
got the car across to Odessa where
they're staying with friends and so they
have some first hand experience and the
dangers from the skies here and we sat
for about 10 15 20 minutes down in the
subway surrounded by all the old tourist
trinket shops that are all closed down
now and I got talking to them about how
stressful it is for as parents they've
got two little children being caught up
in this war that nobody here had asked
for and so preparations here are still
very much ongoing you can't go anywhere
in this city without seeing barricades
sandbags military everywhere there are
even some tanks and some other technical
Vehicles dotted around surround sort of
covered with camouflage that a lot of
the locals have been spending weeks now
making but the main eyes are out here
into the Black Sea because for Odessa
this is one of the big watch points here
we're close to the port major
infrastructure and we know still slowly
but surely there is a a naval build up
here in the Black Sea and it's sort of
any time from now we would expect
perhaps to hear
um something happened this morning we
heard an explosion That Shook the
windows of our hotel I was talking about
it on Sky News earlier we understand
that that was a control detonation
carried out by the Ukrainian military
down on the beach so it just goes to
sure that it can be a confusing picture
sometimes and it takes a while to try to
establish what is actually going on but
for a period of time a lot of people are
on edge thinking you know is this it is
this the beginning of the advancement
onto Odessa but if you go out into the
town it can appear very normal people
are getting on with things but slowly
and surely shops have begun to close
life has started to slow down the
markets are quieter and there is a sense
here that this might be you know that
many many hope it isn't but this might
be the Calm before the storm
Nick updating us there from Odessa thank
you well let's get the latest analysis
on the situation on the ground in
Ukraine come on in Melbourne has the
latest at the Sky News Center Kamali
thank you very much Anna and nickel I'm
joined by air Vice Marshall Sean Bell
who's an advisor at Universal defense
and Security Solutions uh Sean thanks so
much for being with us so this map we'll
be looking at for the past few days it
doesn't seem to have changed very much
what does that tell us about where we
are at the stage in the war
yes I think we've all been watching this
map very closely looking for movement
expansion of the red areas seeing that
as an assessment of progress by the
Russian military and the fact that it
hasn't moved I think tells us a clear
story because either they're having a
day off which I think is highly unlikely
or in reality I think what we're seeing
is a massive resupply of fuel uh food
armaments ready for the next phase of
their military push so they'll be moving
men and arms into these areas that they
already hold rather than trying to take
more territory that's correct yes and
what does this tell us about the fact
that the map does seem a bit static the
way that the ukrainians are able to
defend the territory at the moment well
the ukrainians are doing a clearly an
outstanding job not just the military
but also the um the civilian population
they've been very determined very brave
very courageous and I think against a
much bigger Enemy by dragging them into
the urban battle I think particularly of
late we're also seeing some really
effective counter-attacks which whilst
tactically may not be that effective as
an aggressor you hope you have the
initiative all the time and momentum
what the Ukrainian is doing very
effectively is showing that they've
still got some fight in them and they
are causing the Russians to to think
again and have and second guess what's
going on now while the Russians may be
bolstering the areas in the the northern
East that they hold in the South it's a
bit of a different story we know uh that
the southern city of Kirsten has been
taken by the Russians and there is more
movement to try and uh take some of the
other Southern cities namely Odessa and
maripole let's take a closer look at the
South Mountain as how the fight for this
part of Ukraine is going apparently Sean
I think part of it we've got to
speculate what Putin's strategic
objectives are given his relative lack
of progress and I think we're seeing
Kiev to the north and in the South
because obviously it's the center of the
political power but in the South if you
look back 200 years Russia used to own
the whole of this coastal region onto
the Black Sea and I think if you believe
the um the principle that Putin is
looking to reclaim some of that land I
think we're seeing initially a link
between the Crimea and Mother Russia so
therefore taking that link of the land
link and of course Mario Paul provides a
major blocker to that and that's why
it's so important and that's where we
saw that airstrike yesterday on that
theater that's right and I think we're
they're putting more and more pressure
on to the defending forces I think what
we haven't seen yet but just pops up in
your news feed before is Odessa clearly
is another part of that strategy the
trouble is it's a long way away from
other Russia so resupply so how would
you put pressure on Odessa you might use
Naval forces to do that because you
don't have such long lines of
communication and we'll see where they
move to next okay Sean for now thank you
very much
yes thanks to both of you well the
defense secretary Ben Wallace is in
Warsaw for talks with his polish
counterpart their discussions are
focusing on the war in Ukraine of course
and also the security of NATO's Eastern
flank and he has just announced new
military support
very right the Britain stands by Poland
as Poland
carries much of the burden of the
consequence of this war and stand tall
and brave to stand up to their threats
from Russia
that's why today I can announce we are
going to deploy the sky saber medium
range anti-air missile system to Poland
with about a hundred Personnel to make
sure that we stand alongside Poland and
protecting her airspace from any further
aggression by Russia
okay
well let's get the very latest from
Warsaw now and go to Sky's Lisa Holland
at least a little bit like we heard from
Joe Biden last night in the absence of a
no-fly zone it does appear that Western
allies are trying to provide an anti-air
systems for Ukraine
hi Anna yes I mean I think it's
absolutely the kind of bolstering up in
the event of the worst case scenario
um obviously what's going on uh on the
ground in Ukraine the concern is that
somehow it might spill over the border
and we saw that attack didn't we on a
Ukrainian military base just 15 miles
from the Polish border killing 35 people
a few days ago so to that end the UK's
defense secretary Ben Wallace who was in
NATO yesterday talking to his
counterparts there has arrived in the
Polish Capital Warsaw this morning to
speak to the Polish defense minister and
we had this announcement of this Sky
saber
anti-aircraft defense system the British
system which is going to be deployed now
to the Polish border and it's all all
about Shoring up that Polish border
running alongside the Russian border the
deployment is well of about 100
personnel and the aim of that system an
anti-aircraft system too somehow it's
got the capability to launch a it's
missiles three times further than its
predecessor so it would uh take out
potentially smart bombs and also fighter
jets so Ben Wallace said talking about
the unity amongst NATO and that's just
as important as well not just the
military but also the words uh sending a
message of unity amongst NATO defense
ministers and NATO leaders just in case
there were any thoughts there in the
back of Vladimir Putin's mind to try to
spread and escalate this conflict
sure
Lisa live there in Warsaw let's just
bring you some breaking news concerning
p and o'd be 70s people let's find out
more our business presenter Ian King is
in the city right bring us up to date
then Ian
well Anna as we've been reporting all
morning there have been uh suspensions
of uh Ferries by Pino ferries all
morning they've suspended all Crossings
pending a Company announcement we now
have had that announcement and the
company is going to be making 800
employees redundant with immediate
effect I'll read you the statement it
says uh piano ferries plays a critical
role in keeping trade flowing Supply
chains moving and collecting families
and friends across the North and Iris
Sea and the English Channel we've been
at the heart of this service for years
and we are committed to serving these
vital routes however in its current
State piendo Ferries is not a viable
business we have made a 100 million
pound loss year on year which has been
covered by our parents DP world this is
not sustainable our survival is
dependent on making Swift and
significant changes now without these
changes there is no future for piano
ferries and the company goes on to say
these circumstances have resulted in a
very difficult but necessary decision
which was only taken after seriously
considering all the available options as
part of the process we are starting
today we are providing 800 seafarers
with immediate Severance notices and
we'll be compensating them for this lack
of advance notice with enhanced
compensation packages in making this
tough decision we are securing the
future viability of our business which
employs an additional two and a half
thousand two thousand two hundred people
and supports billions in trade in and
out of the UK and we are ensuring that
we can continue serving our customers in
a way that they've demanded from us for
many years so essentially this is uh
nearly one in three employees being made
redundant by P and O ferries with
immediate effects this is the third year
running that the company has made a loss
it was bought by dubai-based DP World in
2019 for 322 million pounds it's made
losses over 2019 and into 2020 mainly
due to the pandemic of course 2021 we've
we've learned there today they made
another 100 million pound loss the
company stressing it has never taken a
dim even from the business but
nonetheless will this will come as a
considerable shock I imagine to
employees the rmt union is already
talking about potentially uh staging
sit-ins on board some of the uh ferries
that have been uh sat aside and won't be
sailing today so more on that throughout
the afternoon here but that's the
immediate headline 800 redundancies
going at piano ferries with immediate
effect
in the shop for passengers no doubt two
feels like a rite of passage isn't it
taking your children on a ferry like
that well plenty more still to come here
from leviv in Ukraine including we will
go live to kharkiv to talk to a resident
living inside the besiege city
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm inzamam Rasheed and I'm Skies north
of England correspondent telling stories
from this culturally Rich region I call
home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
[Music]
Taliban found your family what would
happen I think they're just going to
straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in all levels of
cricket I was in the balcony a couple of
times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
I just felt physically sick so I was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic GPS were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Music]
well Ukraine's second second City hockey
have seen some of the heaviest
bombardment by the Russians with reports
of hundreds of civilians killed there
over the last three weeks well joining
me now from hageev is one of the city's
residents from ashaco and very good to
talk to you Roma thank you very much
indeed for joining us and from what
we've heard I have to say parts of
khakive sound absolutely hellish at the
moment so bring us up to date what's the
last 24 hours been like and are you safe
now where you are
yes thank you for uh for contacting me
and letting me uh Express the the
situation and feeling about the
situation that now is Hurricane City
yeah the the hurricane is Shelton bombs
starting the first day of this war and
the Russian Reyes in harkive with his
shot and Bob and bobbed mostly uh and uh
now me and my family we escaped from one
of such rayan it is still shout during
all these few weeks this Ray and it's
called saltafka uh where they're they're
almost third part of the citizens of
harkiv live it is shelled during all
these three weeks many houses ruined
many houses damaged and many people are
injured or even killed according to
official information from the city
Authority during the last day 4 49 times
city was shelled by rockets and bombs
now me and my family we escaped from
that tree and and we are hiding in
another one Bob Ryan of the city my son
is 12 years old and he is still with us
because of the big family I cannot move
from the city in by one car but we are
trying to survive this circumstances
somehow as almost every family in the
city
Roma help us understand what it is like
to live under the sound of that shelling
it's been coming closer I know to many
people
um you know bodies have been lying in
the streets help us understand the the
fear and and the trepidation you must
all be feeling
it's horrible
I'm I'm honest it's horrible because
even it is not shelled uh where you live
but you hear every hour the sounds of
bombing the sounds of shelling and
Rockets blowing on the streets in the
houses and you expect every time that it
could come to your house to your family
so it's not if it is not even the the
the the danger of the killing but it's
very emotional situation very stressful
situation uh
even for the adults but especially for
children who's under these circumstances
in the city it's awful
and do you have to take two bunkers to
bomb shelters and if so how many nights
have you spent down there and what are
the conditions like
well people try to hide in a kind of
shelters bomb shelters but there are no
many uh specific prepared bomb shelters
in the city most people hide in the
Metro stations which could be uh could
be considered as a bomb shelter and
people can survive there but
circumstances there is not very well uh
City authorities try to handle
volunteers try to help people to survive
there to provide and they provide water
and food and some blankets and other
stuff that can help people but anyway it
is when you spend there not one or two
days but weeks and in some stations
there are more than six or even 700
people gathered in one place you can
imagine what the circumstances there
what is a situation of people there it's
awful and other people who cannot hide
in metro station they hide in a basement
of the many flats uh houses but you know
it's it's it is dangerous too but it is
not prepared for special shelters there
some people uh they hide in the school
basement but again it is not special
prepared for such uh for such
circumstances for such purposes
in a private sector for example uh there
are no bomb shelters people try to hide
in a uh some underground place where
they keep the food for example like
potatoes and some conservation Etc but
again it is not special prepared for
such for such purposes so people can can
try to hide anywhere where it is somehow
possible to save their lives
at Roma your cocky is very close isn't
it to the to the border with Russia
people describe it as Russian speaking
or ethnically Russian so are you you
know how do you feel about the fact that
it's Russians that are that are shelling
this city
well many people in hurricane and I do
believe that many people in country they
didn't believe that this horror Could
Happen even my friends who admire Russia
and President of Russia and who believe
that that country is kind to us and they
you know in these days the the
absolutely change their mind and they do
believe that now Russia
help us
to
to become a nationalists just because
before that many people believe that
Russia's they are kind of brother to our
country but now they've done everything
to change this attitude on an opposite
way
I know you said you can't all fit in one
car to leave but you know if you could
if you could find a way out
um would you go right now and in some
senses do you just wish you'd got out
faster
yeah we will try to do this
and it wasn't possible too dangerous
no it's not you know it's not dangerous
because
um
well
every time there is some dangerous and
risky situation but uh fortunately steel
uh there are two main roads from harkive
that could be used to Escape From the
City uh to the center uh of the country
and further to the Western Ukraine it is
still possible because harkib is not
circled uh by the Russian Russian army
thanks to Ukrainian Army it is still the
situation when it is possible for people
to come out of the city
well we wish you a very very best of
luck and all your family room thank you
so much for sharing your story with us
and um you know fingers crossed um that
you get out safely thank you Roma Shaker
there who is a hotkey as you heard
resident who is with his wife her
parents his parents and his 12 year old
son
um they can't all get in one vehicle and
that's part of his problem about about
leaving
well still to come from leviv here in
Western Ukraine could the ongoing talks
bring about an end to the war I'll be
speaking to a former Ukrainian Diplomat
from Kiev
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
says Russia is doing all it can to make
progress in talks to end the war in
Ukraine but he has reportedly made a
series of 15 demands many of them are
things Ukraine considers red lines which
the country will not agree to well let's
talk more about this hope for diplomacy
joining me now from Kiev is the former
deputy foreign minister of Ukraine Danny
lolubakiewski good to have you on
certainly this time yesterday Ukraine
suggested that Russia was now being more
realistic in its demands there was talk
of Keith becoming a neutral Country Now
Putin has talked about scum and the need
for purification and Joe Biden is called
President Putin a war criminal
um this is hardly the greatest backdrop
for peace talks is it
uh dear Anna thank you very much for
having me on the Sky News today and but
before answering your question let me
express my compassion uh and full
solidarity with Roman from harkio and
from for with many Ukrainian families
all around Ukraine who suffer from this
cynical unprovoked War based against our
nation by Putin which is unforgivable
and this is unimaginable of those
sufferings we feel it all across Ukraine
in in Malibu and here in cave still
continues to suffer from the shellings
from the explosions from the attacks of
Russia's uh military forces trying to to
continue to attack and to Siege Ukraine
and but they are matched with very Str
with this strength and strong Spirit of
the Ukrainian Armed Forces so Russia
continues to lie they simply lie they
simply try to deceive and here let me
say that being a diplomat I definitely
it goes without even saying that I stand
strongly for any any possible option to
ensure peace negotiations for that I
support president zielinski and his
efforts and the efforts of the big
Ukraine team International Ukraine team
aimed at
ensuring the peace process and ensuring
the defending Ukraine and dasming
Russia's invasion
however I am far from being optimistic
that bilateral talks with Russia may
bring any kind of necessary and tangible
results and the reasons the reason is
very simple Russia's simple simply
breaks its word and Russia you know
Russia never never
stick in their respects to the
commitments it had done if you know
before so if Russia has simply violated
all bilateral and multilateral
commitments of in in its relations with
Ukraine so no trust
well even before an agreement this
skepticism isn't there military action
can certainly feel like it's stalled
when actually what's happening is
resupply you know is the fear among some
ukrainians that in a sense Russia is
playing with these peace talks in order
to get that resupply effort underway
uh definitely that we have to explore
possible possible options and tools to
ensure the ceasefire and to ensure the
necessary security conditions for
Ukraine so for that I believe that it is
important to continue the the the
bilateral discussion but also the
multilateral pressure upon upon Russia
in order to ensure that at this
particular moment the level of security
for Ukraine and for the for for the
ukrainians uh in my opinion there is a
way out how to move ahead and for that
we have to explore three major options
three priorities the point number one
yesterday the international court of
justice the United Nations International
court of justice has ordered
in its rulings that Russia shall
immediately suspend military operations
in the territory of Ukraine it goes
without saying that Russia will violate
even this binding ruling but
nevertheless it is important for all of
us to stick to the international law and
to bring fujin and his regime to Justice
Point number two we have to move ahead
with the multilateral talks so here I
recommend the Ukrainian government and I
and I call upon our International
Partners to make everything possible to
ensure that there is a multilateral
negotiation team which can go ahead with
the agenda of of in our common and
strong pressure against the the
aggressor and and finally uh that we the
best must not be distracted by the uh
so-called peaceful Solutions of
President Putin I repeat this again they
try to deceive us so
there is a clear here the road map how
to move ahead to provide Ukraine with
necessary defensive weapons air defense
anti-rockets of instruments for to
ensure that there is a strong
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine and
financial assistance and sanctions
against Putin this is what is needed
today
what role do you think China can play in
this you know in terms of a a
multinational effort to bang heads
together the US and the Chinese are
meeting we understand there seems to
have been a meeting here in leviv in
fact with the Chinese Ambassador coming
here so do you think they could be the
one
to make President Putin think again or
will that not happen I mean what do you
think about his behavior Mr Putin's
Behavior
is becoming more clear that even China
understands uh what kind of threat and
challenge is Mr Putin's aggression
against Ukraine so he undermines not
only Ukraine security and delight and he
kills not only Ukrainian lies but he is
aimed and drugged and and he targets the
International System so he is a danger
for China itself and for from those
messages and signals what we hear from
uh different sources we understand that
and I hope that this is true that China
understands and comprehends how Syria is
serious is the threat which is coming
from from Moscow we can rely and we can
call upon China to to exercise all their
pressure all their necessary pressure on
Russia to stop the aggression however uh
much more should be done and here let me
say that the role of the permanent
members of the P5 of the United Nations
security security account also is
apartment importance and we uh I believe
that the Ukrainian diplomacy explores
this this this track of talks with with
the with China uh encouraging them to
continue
um the policy which would uh prove that
China is a reliable partner of Ukraine
an influential partner in the
international politics
well Danilo lubakiewski great to have
your expertise on their former deputy
foreign minister former diplomatic
advisor to the Ukrainian prime minister
and also director of the Kiev security
forum and uh no doubt you're watching as
we all are to see how those talks
progress thank you very much indeed
well as we just heard there are a number
of red lines in those negotiations
President zielinski's Chief of Staff has
told Sky News the Ukraine is not willing
to give up any territory as part of
peace talks but as plumes of smoke from
the fighting Edge closer to the capital
it is clear that some of the very
youngest most helpless are being left to
suffer the dark consequences of this war
well our special correspondent Alex
Crawford is in carefanda sent this
report
the capital's Skyline is very different
now
kiev's 18th century Saint Andrews Church
but with a backdrop of battle which is
getting closer
[Music]
the city's been put under strict curfew
to try to limit the lives lost but
there's no protecting against attacks
like these
second missile strikes less than a
minute later
the Ukrainian demands for a no-fly zone
grow more Ardent with every strike and
despite hints of progress on peace talks
the President's chief of staff told us
there were red lines they would not
cross
would you be prepared to give up tombas
look
I say an answer to your questions
we don't
discussed our freedom our independence
our territory Integrity our sovereignty
all another issue
we can see things and discussed and my
presidents my presidents are ready to
sitting in any days
in any place
but you're not prepared to give up any
territory
yes no territory yes
they're on the lookout for Russian
saboteurs we filmed the Detention of
these two suspects before the capital's
curfew
the ukrainians are worried that Russian
agents have infiltrated the main city
and are acting as guides for possible
airstrikes leaving tags or markers on
potential targets or just acting as
informants on troop and Military
movements
these concerns have heightened over the
past 24 hours as the Russian soldiers
inch closer to Kiev and the center of
Ukrainian power
amongst those at risk of being trapped
in the capital are scores of surrogate
babies
there are so many the nursery is a
constant hubbub of crying demands for
attention
the babies are being cared for in a
basement which has been turned into an
underground shelter by a very small team
of babysitters
these women have left their families to
look after these little ones after the
baby's actual parents couldn't reach
them because of all the fighting
[Music]
you have to understand this is war this
babysitter says not everyone is able to
come the airports are all closed so
their parents just can't pick them up
we love all the babies another says as
she explains they become part of our
hearts our family and when the parents
do take them away we cry she tells us
but with heavy fighting around the
capital it's meant the women looking
after the babies here are also all that
stands between them and the bombings
there are so many acts of defiance being
played out on these streets
one soldier and his flute and the
national anthem we won't be ruled by
others it goes in so many ways he speaks
for his country
Alex Crawford Sky News Kiev
well next orphaned and displaced we
speak to a man trying to help children
to safety here in Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
for the people here are praying quietly
to themselves
they're becoming very sensitive of
having the media around
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
minutes and now it's coming from both
sides and it's moving this way
every time they touch and they sprayed
sprayed spray made for people who want
Clarity in an uncertain world
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
well caught up in the midst of the war
here in Ukraine are thousands of
displaced children some of them orphans
let's speak now then to Jeremy lock
chief of operations at aerial Recovery
Group which is helping to provide
safeguarding to Ukrainian orphans
fleeing the war welcome to you Jeremy
and Seth me amidst the horror of this
war we desperately need some good news
don't we so tell us about some of the
the children that you've managed to get
out of those areas of conflict into you
know places where I am in Western
Ukraine which definitely feel a bit
safer
yes uh thank you for having me and and I
appreciate uh the opportunity to be on
here and explain what we are doing
because we are moving these these
children in these organs that are in
these war-torn areas Keith and nikolov
there's these areas that children do not
belong in and we're safeguarding escort
am2 the relative safety of the West and
we're doing this in partnership with
Ukraine's government
what are the specific things you need to
think about when moving children because
there were some premature babies that
were taken out of of Kiev it's you know
for them it turned out to be a 20-hour
journey and they had to pack the tiny
babies with hot water bottles
um as if they were still in incubators
now you wouldn't have that with with all
of your children but what are the
specific needs of children on the move
or you just you have to imagine these
these children are sometimes there are
hundreds of them that we move we've been
able to uh rescue 403 to date and we do
have to take all those in consideration
we were escorting one that was HIV
positive with many with diabetes there's
all these medical concerns that do have
to be pre-coordinated so we can care for
them uh when we when we move them it is
a very long journey these children have
been underground for up to a week
sometimes listening to shelling fighting
experiencing things that children should
not have to experience so we do our best
to be able to care for them as best as
possible with the resources that we have
and we bring them like I said from those
dangerous areas to the relative safety
of the West
is it that much harder if they are
orphans they don't have you know a
parental hug to get them through it
yes it is it does um
it it brings different challenges you
have to understand that
Ukraine has a very large population of
Orphans over 200 000. there's a natural
a National Registry of these orphans and
it's important that we work through
Ukraine's government to ensure that
they're not going across International
borders without some sort of
accountability so that's why we do get
them out of the dangerous areas
immediately and we bring them to the
west and ensure that there is that
accountability before they do move
because they don't have they don't have
parents that are after looking after
them they do have wonderful caretakers
that are there but sometimes there might
be one caretaker for for 50 children so
it's a very difficult and tedious
process to ensure that we are escorting
them properly and and safely and also
ensuring that we do minimize the chances
of human trafficking
it is getting
hotter such as the the scale of this so
how are you finding accommodation for
them even if it is just for for days
weeks or perhaps a couple of months
yeah that is the difficult part but what
we do have unfortunately is we are
working in Partnership Ukraine's
government with their Ministry of
Defense we have a memorandum of
understanding which gives us the ability
to I want to say commandeer but use
facilities such as schools that aren't
currently being in use and and other
sorts of facilities that we can then
identify and we can build up the
infrastructure within those facilities
that allow us to temporarily care for
these children a little bit longer and
then once we do have that accountability
we push them across um one of the
borders under the supervision of
Ukraine's government to ensure that they
are handed off properly and safely to
other places and just get them out of
this terrible situation
oh
well we wish you um the very best of
luck with your work it's it's a massive
task as we know Jeremy lock chief of
operations at aerial Recovery Group
which is working alongside the Ukrainian
government thank you very much indeed
thank you
now amidst the devastation of this war
Vladimir zielinski has become something
of a global icon now the Ukrainian
president has been immortalized in Lego
form with manufacturing of his
minifigure extended following what they
called overwhelming interest
well citizen break which makes custom
printed Lego products is producing more
figures of the Ukrainian president to
sell as part of a charity campaign
they've already raised almost 12 and a
half thousand pounds after selling
figures of Mr zielinski and would you
believe Molotov cocktails well in a
statement citizen brick said they hope
to raise 75 000 pounds to support
efforts to get medical supplies to
refugees
well next on the sky news we will have
more from here and the very latest on
that breaking news concerning p and O
Ferries
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello this is the Sarah J me show with
me at beldenotti the top story is at two
breaking news 800 p o Ferry staff are
made immediately redundant amid a 100
million pound a year company loss
searching for survivors a rescue
operation is underway after Russia bombs
A theater where more than a thousand
people were taking cover
video emerges of the families who were
Sheltering for safety as the number of
casualties is yet to become clear
meanwhile Western intelligence suggests
President Putin's Invasion has largely
stalled on all fronts amid reports a
fourth Russian general is killed
reunited at last the moment they've been
waiting for as nazanin zagari Radcliffe
and Anusha Azuri arrive home following
their Iran ordeal
it's been a long time coming and it's
just the most wonderful news to hear
it's been a lovely 24-hour
interest rates rise again with a warning
from the bank of England that the cost
of living will keep going up
and celebrating St Patrick's Day massive
crowds gather on the streets of Dublin
after covid-19 canceled large events for
two years
foreign
[Music]
we begin with some breaking news p o
ferries has made 800 of its staff
redundant effective immediately and
canceled all its services for the next
few days the company says it's acted to
secure its long-term future calls
today's decision very difficult but
necessary union bosses have described
the move as scandalous well we have a
statement from the company and it says
in its current state p o ferries is not
a viable business we've made a hundred
million pound uh loss year on year which
has been covered by our parents DP world
this is not sustainable uh the statement
went on to say as part of the process
we're starting today we're providing 800
seafarers with immediate Severance
notices and will be compensating them
for this lack of advance notice with
enhanced compensation packages a
Department of Transport spokesperson
said the Department of Transport is
working with the Kent resilience forum
and all its local Partners to ensure the
free flow of traffic in Kent there are
other operators running services on
cross-channel routes so that passengers
and goods can continue to travel
ministers and officials that will be
speaking with piano ferries later today
to understand more about those changes
and the impact on staff and passengers
well our business presenter Ian King is
in the city let's go straight to him and
Ian a complete shock for the employees
what sense is there that this was coming
down the pipeline well this is a
business that has been struggling for a
number of years it was bought by
dubai-based DP world back in 2019 for
322 million pounds and it hasn't made a
penny profit since in fact it's been
loss making ever since DP World acquired
it it lost some 38 million pounds in
2019 in 2020 obviously the year that the
pandemic Struck it lost nearly 86
million pounds the 2021 results have yet
to be published but you read the
statement there from piano ferries in
which it's reported it admitted to a 100
million pound loss so that's cumulative
losses getting on for 250 million pounds
over the last three years I wouldn't say
that all of this business's problems are
down to the pandemic although clearly
that has been pretty devastating in
terms of what it's meant for passenger
travel over the last two years they've
been added complications I think by the
Northern Ireland protocol uh obviously
that requires Customs checks for uh
inbound traffic into Northern Ireland
and that has clearly added to
complications to the business it owns
apart from obviously the well-known
Dover de Calais Crossing p o also
operates at Cairn Ryan to learn Crossing
from Scotland to Northern Ireland across
the Irish he also operates from uh
Liverpool to Dublin and from Hull to
Rotterdam as well but I suspect the
added complications of the normal line
of protocol have probably not helped and
we also know from recent from previous
company filings that there is a
significant liability owed to the
Merchant Navy uh seafarers pension fund
as well in the latest accounts to be
filed uh p o recognized a liability of
some 146 million pounds and this was of
course a business that didn't receive
any support from the government during
the pandemic its appeals for support
were turned down and DP world the parent
company actually had to carry on making
loans to p o ferries to keep it afloat
during the Pandemic those total some 40
million pounds between the the late 2020
and early 2021 it may be possible that
there have been subsequent loans made to
the company by its parent company since
then we don't know about those so
basically a business that has been
struggling for quite some period of time
worth pointing out as the business
points out in that statement that uh the
move the actions they're taking today
are aimed at making this a sustainable
business long term there have been heavy
job losses already in recent years
shortly after the outset of the pandemic
piano ferries made 1100 employees
redundant that at the time equated to
around one in four employees there have
clearly been other job losses since
because they're down now as a result of
this uh these 800 immediate redundancies
today to some 2 200 employees so this is
a much much smaller business than once
it was and clearly one that has been
struggling for a number of years now all
right thank you very much Ian King
they're live in the city well in the
last few minutes uh p o ferries has
issued another statement in it they've
said piano fairies has today announced a
program of work to become a more
competitive and efficient operator
providing a better service to our
customers across the tourism and Freight
Industries while we enact these changes
there will be significant disruption
across p o Ferry services over the next
few days however we are working to
minimize the impact on your journey if
traveling on our Dover Calais route
please arrive at the Port as booked and
we will arrange to get you away on an
alternative carrier as quickly as
possible